曹雪芹协假家试验负语了每个人不同的雅记。这从压换的名字就能看出来。大姐云春的压换名叫报琴,二姐云春的压头名叫司棋,三妹妹探春的压换叫做试书,四妹妹西春的压头叫做入话,分别对应了情奇书化四详记呢。
原主中,只有云春因早年入宫,我们不得而知他的情意。
云春喜欢下棋,探春擅长书法,西春拿手做话,这三项技能确实书中明确写到了。其中最引人注目的就是四妹妹西春。
红楼第四只回,因刘老老称赞大官员景色天下南有,家母意识性棋,点名西春,让她给大官员化一副行乐图。
这个任务对西春而言,穿撑强人所难,可爱于家母当中许愿,她没办法拒绝只能硬的头皮答应。
为何说家母此举是强人所难,曹雪芹随后就给出了答案。
当西春因化行乐图,要向大官员时射请假时,重精拆集体讨论了做话的问题。
通过这场对话,我们才发现,西春完全没有能力完成这一副行乐图。
原主是这么写的,西春道,原说只画这原子的,左儿老太太又说,单画了原子成个房样子了,叫连人都画上,就像行乐似的才好。
我又不会着攻戏楼台,不会画人物,又不好不回,正为这个为难的。
西春既不会攻戏楼台,也不会画人物,只会击比写意,她完全不具备画行乐图的能力。
这也是曹雪芹的写实之处,
仲然西春是天才少女,也远没有达到画功老辣的地步,她终究还是个孩子。
后文里,西春的确画出了行乐图,虽然前八这回结束时,并没有明确提及这副画是否画完,但西春的确画了一部分。
故而相铃入住大官员,拜林代域为师,学习做师时,就曾跟重金拆一起去买相物,见赏这副未完成的行乐图。
西春能做行乐图,除了个人能力以外,更重要的原因是外界的帮助。
比如她不擅长的攻戏楼台和人物,都是假保育托人相帮,委托了家中亲客,沾死量的攻戏楼台,成日新的美人。
他们的助力才让这副行乐图得以落幕。
在这个过程当中,我们也能品味出很多东西,首先就是西春的性格,她似乎始终有外界保持距离,即便不会画行乐图,也不会主动去请求别人的帮助。
重金拆帮她出谋画侧,完全来自于对西春退出时射的讨论。
由请假时间,延伸到做话的难度,因为要根据做话的难度,确定假期时场,以便给西春放假。
假好保拆集通小做话的流程,这才帮西春收离好了脉路。
我们可以想象,如果保拆不说,其他人又不懂,西春的估计性格又导致她不会主动问别人,那当真是两眼一抹黑,不知道要走多少万路才能画出这副行乐图来。
更值得品味的是假某的态度,她完全不了解西春的做话能力,一开始只说话原子,后来让西春把人物也画上。
再后来,看见虚保琴学下捆眉,又让西春把保琴捆眉也画上,这完全是想起一出事一出。
刘老老进大官员是秋季,大家还在吃歇赏贵,虚保琴学下捆眉已经是冬季了。
一印装素果,眉花冷香,这让西春如何兼顾。
不止如此,加目对做话所需要的时间也完全没有概念。
重庆拆头论做话流程,最终认为需要半年的时间,可加目并不认同这个结论。
当她得知,西春明年端午才能画好时,加目不越到,这还了得,她尽力盖着原子还被功夫了。
随后加目丁主西春不要偷懒,自己年下就要看这幅画。
也就是说,加目压缩了西春的做话时间,原本预计的半年时间,直到第二年端午才能画好。
加目直接砍掉了将近四个月,当年年底就要看到成品,这就成了一个不可能完成的任务。
再后来,这幅行乐图就消失了,我们不知道当年年底时,西春到底有没有感化出来。
或许操工也觉得,这种不可能完成的任务,如果完成了,反倒失针了。
故而这幅画的行踪就成了迷,书中再也没有提及过。
从这些细节里,我们能看出加目身上也存在一些问题。
作为封建时代的大家长,她已经足够开明了。
可在某些方面,她还是显得过于五段强硬。
她的微言始终高高悬挂于重人的头顶之上。
西春明明完成不了这个任务,却始终爱于加目的微言不敢拒绝。
莫说西春,哪怕是被加目重爱至极的临代域,她和加目之间也存在心理距离。
故而第四十五回,金蓝气互抛金蓝鱼,待遇就伤感的告诉宝差。
我母亲去世的早,又无子妹兄弟,我长了今年十五岁,
竟没一个人向你前日的花教导我。
可见加目虽然重爱待遇,却并没有急于待遇亲人般的安全感。
自家人而并私魔,互说真心提及化的经历,对待遇而言更是从未有过。
以至于,宝差规券待遇两句,就让待遇获得了亲人教会班的感受。
待遇的心理,在一种野性的环境下,运仰发酬,没有父母亲人的束缚。
可能也正是这个原因,导致待遇幼年时口齿风力,说话不饶人。
因为没有长辈告诉她,这样做不好。
同时,待遇始终对自己的未来心存优虑,
正如许多读者所期待的那样。
加目完全可以单独跟待遇说之心话,了解她的想法,不许明言,
只以言语暗示的方式,莫许莫是英语,以宽世待遇的心。
可从待遇的心理状态来看,加目并没有去深度了解待遇,也没有说过读者所期待的宽心话。
加目的作为无许科则,从时代角度来看,她已是足够开明的封建大家长,十分难得。
真正需要反思的是我们今日。
因为从现实来看,封建大家长的基因并没有销亡,这股血脉仍在许多人的血管中流淌着。
她像一个优灵,赢绕在许多中国是家庭的上空。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。